no but speaking of you of your own news
show you have your no podcast right oh
yeah yeah I mean in the last few years
of my career I really realized how much
I loved inspiring people and I had this
cool platform where just being out there
was enough and so after racing I thought
the one thing that I really want to keep
doing is doing that and giving people
inspiration to let it making sure that
they understand I can do anything and
setting big goals and and digging deeper
into themselves to grow and so this show
came up as an idea with between a group
of us and I was like I think this is
perfect so I mean it's so much fun look
I want when you get interviewed
you don't learn crap because you just
talk about yourself exactly it's much
harder to flip it but when you get in it
when you do interview people you learn a
ton right like I'm sure you've been
meeting so many even more people than
you already met yes and actually it's
like my first time like in my life and
I've actually just shut up like which is
working out it turns out I like
listening yeah I didn't know this about
myself
I sympathize yes I've said that one of
the hardest things for me to do is to
just shut up and listen and it's almost
like a discipline and exercise for me
and growth so doing the show is really
good and those shows are usually between
gosh an hour to an hour and a half so
that's a lot of listening yeah I didn't
feel like it takes a minute to really
invest and you're wanting to do
something that's powerful and inspiring
it takes a minute you can't that's not
like a five-minute thing that's it
that's cool it takes a while so we're
gonna be here a while
so I'm gonna break down that barrier in
eight minutes
oh no challenge yeah well that's the
other thing is I'm very very vulnerable
and very honest and if somebody asked me
a question I will I will answer it and
it's probably why so many people love
you you know and is retiring good yeah I
mean like I do feel like I'm growing so
much but when people ask me you're
retired how is it and I'm like I mean
vacations farmers market I can lean into
something like that yeah so no it's not
just that but I mean I have a wine named
somnium so I've been able to do more
stuff for that yeah I do speaking
engagements and all kinds of stuff but
but a lot of vacations I love that yeah
everybody's getting a bottle of wine guy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you're gonna watch me drink it no no but
I was like asking drivers this like
you're driving your whole life right but
what about your driver's test cuz I find
that most I find that most of y'all
actually did horribly on your driver's
test I was good you were good
well the teacher was in passenger seat
and they have an extra brake on their
side and I don't slow I was he was
really nervous and hovered over the
brake a lot because I didn't slow down
because of brake lights I slowed down
because of closing rates so until the
car actually came back to me from a
distance perspective I didn't slow down
so I freaked him out all the time worked
out but I was I think he's told stories
about me afterwards I think they were
good I don't know did you do well in
your driving test you - no failed mine
you know no I did I did pretty good you
know my worst driving experience the
first time I tried to drive listened to
a book on tape
you know because I thought it was a
really good idea in the person where I
was like oh man I've been sleep for 15
minutes I was like me too
[Laughter]
this is such a bad idea to do still work
have you ever done any with like cars
and I hire people due to precision
driving for the most part I actually
jump underwear I hire them to do it I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this